Thank you so much Rachel.
It's a pleasure to be with you all.
I'm really thrilled to be here.
It's fun to be in the Google plex,
so here's the situation we have the
best technology that the world has ever
seen,
has ever had to deal with conflict
and yet family conflict abounds,
workplace conflict, community
conflict, international conflict.
What's what? What's the situation?
We've got principled negotiation.
We've got diplomacy, we've got
win-win technologies. What's wrong?
What's missing?
I'm arguing today we need
new conflict technology.
There are at least two types of conflicts,
so we're going to talk about two of them
and then we're going to focus on one.
There's routine conflict,
right? I'm hot, you're cold.
I want the window open.
You want the window closed.
How are we going to solve this?
I'm calling that it's really a main
frame problem and it can be and has been
solved over the last many years.
Those kinds of problems are solved by
conflict resolution. It can be resolved,
right? We figure out how to have a win
win solution and we can figure that out.
Different from routine conflict is
what I'm calling difficult conflict.
This is the kind of conflict
that comes up again and again.
No matter how many times we try to resolve
it, it just seems to keep coming up.
I'm calling this more like the cloud.
It's more more of a cloud like problem.
It's a complex problem,
array of different factors caused these
kinds of problems and we need to master
these kinds of problems.
Conflict resolution is not adequate
to address these kinds of difficult,
complex, complex conflicts. So,
uh,
what we're going to do today,
I'm going to introduce to you seven
practices that you can use that you can
practice to master conflict.
We're going to rip through them,
cause I normally spend at least
three days going deep into each one,
but we're going to rip through them today
so that you have a sense of what's the
entirety of this set of seven practices.
And uh,
so for those left brainers out there
amongst us, myself included, you might,
you'll be happy.
You'll see,
we're going to walk through them in
a logical sequential order for the,
for the rest of us. I'm going
to tell you a story. Okay.
So for the last 20 years I've Been
Consulting, coaching senior leaders,
CEOs and their senior teams to help them
deal with very difficult conflicts like
the ones we're going to be
about today. And, um, I,
I've worked with people across
many different kinds of industries,
particularly focusing on high
tech professional services,
financial services.
That's my work.
And so I'm going to be
drawing on one story.
It's actually a composite of a couple
of different clients of mine from recent
years, uh, to protect the innocence. So
don't try to guess who these people are.
Um, and, and we're going to walk
through the seven practices using there,
the story as an example so
you can see how it works.
In addition to that, I want this
material to be really relevant to you.
So before we move on,
take a moment and I want you to think of
a difficult come conflict in your life
that you are aware of.
It could be one that you,
yourself are currently experiencing.
It could be one that you are helping
other people in your life deal with or it
could be one that you're simply
aware of from watching the news.
So just take a minute for those of
you watching online, take a moment,
write it down.
And in a minute I'm going to ask you to
turn to someone sitting next to you and
talk about it. But just take
a, take a minute and think of,
write down a difficult conflict that's
important to you so we can really ground
ourselves in. What are we talking
about here? What's important to you?
It could be family, workplace,
national, international community.
Okay.
So now turn to somebody
sitting next to you.
For those of you in the room and uh,
you can make your example generic if you
don't feel comfortable talking to them
about exactly all the details. Or you
can say pass and just listen to them,
but take a minute and tell the other
person or listen to them talk about their
difficult conflict that came to mind.
So just take a minute and do that.
All right, great. Coming back together.
So I want to hear a couple of examples.
Can anyone in like a sentence
sentence or two, tell me what,
what did you say? What is it? Difficult
conflict that's important to you. Yes.
What happened?
Thank you. Yes. I had meant to
say earlier actually then, right.
One very obvious example of difficult
conflict that we in this country are
facing this week as we head into the
presidential election is exactly what you
just said, right? It's
going to, yeah. We're,
we're in the midst of one of the most
conflictual presidential elections we've
ever seen. Thank you. Who else? What,
what's an example of a difficult conflict
might be from your own personal life
might be from work.
Ah,
so you have inside of you have
a conflict going on about well,
should I raise it this way or
should I raise it that way?
Or maybe this third thing is something
I should say. Yes, thank you.
So you have actually conflict going on
inside of yourself about how to deal with
a conflict that you have going on
with somebody else. Makes Sense. Any,
any other brave people? One more
example just to ground us? Yes.
Okay, so cultural differences. I'm, I'm,
yeah,
so there are cultural differences among
people who work at Google in different
countries.
Is that what you're saying?
Tell me more what you mean Google
versus the Chinese government. Huh.
Okay, great. Got It.
There are regulations that Chinese that
the Chinese government has placed on
Google and Google has to figure out how
to deal with this. Excellent example.
But one of the most, right. That's a great
example of a cloud complex conflicts.
Thank you. Okay, so we have a sense of
what are we talking about here, right?
How many people have ever felt
like conflict is mastering you?
Anyone felt that way? Right? This
conflict is really mastering me,
not the other way around.
So we are going to be talking about
how can we turn that around and master
conflict.
So as I said,
we're going to be talking about
seven practices and here they are.
Map it out except what
is identify your values.
We'll talk more about what specific
values we're talking about.
Transform negative emotions,
invision,
optimal possible outcomes,
prevent unintended negative consequences
and take courageous pattern breaking
action. Okay, and the purpose, why?
Why are we going to do these practices?
The purpose is so that you can live
at your highest potential and master
conflict.
That's what it's about.
So we're going to take each of these
in turn and we're going to apply this a
story that I'm about to tell
you to this conflict number one,
practice number one,
map it out.
So often in difficult conflicts it
seems like we're dealing with just me,
us vs them, right? China versus Google.
But in actuality it's much
more complex than that.
And so paradoxically,
the first piece of advice about how to
deal with difficult conflict is not to do
anything at all.
It's actually to take a step
back and observe the situation,
observe the situation.
And one of the best ways that I know
how to do that is to draw a map for
yourself.
I'm going to show you in a minute.
Well here it is,
right?
This is one of the most complex maps that
has probably ever been drawn to show a
conflict situation.
The U s military drew this map
of the situation in Afghanistan.
And I show you this map because it's
really an exaggerated example of what I'm
talking about,
about taking a situation that might
look like one side versus another side,
and then really seeing what, what's,
what's the complex situation that's
going on here? So I told you,
I'm going to tell you this story
about a CEO and a salesperson that,
uh,
that he works with.
Your organization is a high tech
startup company in New York City.
MMM.
Bob Is the CEO.
Sally is his top salesperson and
they've been friends for 15 years.
They're co founders of this firm.
They founded the firm eight years ago.
I'm Bob's coach.
He hired me.
I've been working with him
for about a year and a half.
And about six months before
I started working with him,
he and Sally had a big,
big blow up screaming match on
a street corner in Manhattan.
Why you ask?
Well,
it's because they were talking
about Sally's compensation package.
This was something that Bob had wanted to
bring up with her for a very long time.
Right. Just like your example.
Oh, what am I going to say?
So he was probably like you going
back and forth in his mind of,
should I say this? Should I
say that? And it took him,
it took him a long time to even raise
the issue with her because he knew from
past experience that anytime he did,
she got very upset.
And sure enough this time they went
out for lunch as they often did, um,
near their office,
casually as friends and they're walking
back from lunch to the office and um,
he decides to bring up the
topic and he says the words,
your compensation package.
And according to him,
she immediately starts screaming at him,
how could you bring this up? All that.
So what does he do?
Screams right back.
So there they are yelling at each other
on the street corner and at some point
he just says, you know what? Forget
it. Forget I even ever mentioned it.
You can keep the package
the way that it is.
And that was the end of the situation.
Now,
what you need to know is the reason why
he felt so strongly about bringing up
the issue is that Sally is compensation
package had not changed since the
company was founded eight years
ago and she was being compensated,
uh, as if she, they were
still back eight years ago.
But now the company has grown
tremendous amounts and according to Bob,
she could even,
she could just not even pick up the phone
and she would max out her commissions,
right? She would make as much money as
she possibly could for herself because the
company is doing lots of other things
to help sell, sell, sell there.
So their software.
So that's the situation.
The other thing you need to know about
Sally is that she grew up in a family
where her parents didn't have a
lot of money, they were quite poor.
And as a result,
she herself has always been very concerned
about her ability to support herself.
She's single, she's the primary
person taking care of herself.
There's no one else who can take care
of her financially except for her.
So she's got some worries about
her own financial standing.
We also have Sally's coach who's
involved here. Sally's coaches,
a colleague of mine who works with me
at my firm, and who else do we have?
Can't forget about the executive team,
including the CFO,
who also has a stake and cares a lot
about what Sally's compensation package
looks like. And finally,
Bob Spouse, right?
That she's involved here too.
So what started out looking like?
It's just about Bob and Sally.
We map it out and we see
it's more complex than that.
What's the ultimate purpose of
doing an exercise like this?
It's to see levers for change that
we might not have seen otherwise.
Right here we start to see,
hmm.
Some things going on here about
Sally's upbringing. There's,
there's other people involved.
The CFO might be putting pressure on Bob.
All right.
We're not coming up with solutions yet,
but we're observing what,
what is the next practice
is accept what is.
So where the first practice, again, pat,
paradoxically we're taking a step back
rather than jumping in and doing anything.
The second step is quite the
same and even even further, uh,
taking a step back.
So this quote says,
the definition of insanity is doing
the same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result.
How many of us,
how many of you have ever been
in a conflict where you say,
let's do it this way.
Let's do it this way.
And you just keep meeting up
against resistance, right?
Either they push back or
they're just shut down.
So you're not re, regardless of how they
react, it's one of those two things.
They pushed back or they're shut down.
You're not getting anywhere, right?
You could say the same thing.
How many people have had that experience?
I can't imagine it would. You're right.
It's, it's a pretty common experience.
That's what we typically do.
We want them to do it our way.
And so we just keep on telling them,
right?
We might say it in 17 different ways on
17 different days and we start to think
we're actually going insane.
You start to feel insane.
So there has to be a better way.
And what I'm suggesting is that it has
to do with accepting the situation.
Now how,
how do you do that?
Three things.
First is accept who they are.
Second,
except yourself and third,
except the situation.
So to be clear, I don't want
anyone walking out of here saying,
she said we should just agree with
everything that they said. No,
that's not what I'm talking about,
right?
I'm not saying you have to agree with
them and I'm not saying you have to like
them.
I'm just saying,
can you accept what is,
how do you do this?
You ask two questions.
The first question is,
what do I wish were true?
If I'm accepting who they are,
what do I wish were true about them?
So another part of this story
about the CEO and his salesperson,
Bob and Sally. Bob said to
me at some point, you know,
I just wish she wasn't so selfish.
Why does she care so much about her own
compensation to the exclusion of the
company? She doesn't care about the
company. She only cares about herself.
At that point, I looked
at Bob and I said, Bob,
I get that you really wish she
wasn't saying what she's saying,
that she wasn't worried about
her own financial wellbeing.
And
my question for you is,
can you accept
that
that's how she, that's what she's
experiencing in life right now.
She has fear about her own financial
wellbeing and that that may be driving a
lot of her behavior. Can
you accept that? Okay,
now all of a sudden we have some movement.
What about except yourself?
What do you,
what do you think Bob,
the CEO wished he had done differently.
So they're on the street
corner yelling at each other.
He brought it up as they're walking home,
walking back to the office,
he backs down.
What do you think he wishes about himself
that he had done differently in the,
in that situation?
Exactly. Great. Thank you.
He wishes he had brought it up in
a more formal place in a meeting,
in a meeting room in a more
formal way. Great. Yes.
Great.
So I heard you say two things.
One is give her some advanced warning
so that they're not just boom,
she's immediately expected to react.
Give her advanced morning by sending
her an email first saying, hey,
let's talk about this. Um, and,
and also you're saying he shouldn't,
he might wish that he hadn't
said it's going to change,
but rather let's talk about it.
So great.
He probably wishes that
he had done, I, in fact,
I know that he wishes he had done
all those things. Looking back.
So the question for him is he,
except that he didn't do those things,
can he accept his contributions to
the problem? Right. In the past,
his narrative has been, it's all
her fault. It's all her fault.
It's all their fault. It's
all China's fault. Right?
But can we accept the contributions that
we have made to the situation as it is
that he brought it up in the
middle of a street corner,
that he didn't give her advanced warning,
that he brought it up in a way that
didn't give her a chance to even have any
say in the matter at all.
Can he accept his contributions and
except the situation. What do you think,
thinking about yourself now for a minute,
what do you think most people,
what do you tend not to accept
about a difficult conflict?
What's hard about the situation itself?
What do you, what do you wish? Yeah. Yeah.
You just want the uncomfortable feeling
to go away. It's really uncomfortable.
Most people, if you ask them, what do you
wish could change about the situation?
They just say make it go away and fast.
Right.
It never feels like I've
done anything wrong.
I wish they could just see that they're
wrong and I'm right and that would end
it. Yeah, exactly. Yes. Yes.
It is hard. Exactly. In fact, the things,
these seven practices as you're already,
I'm sure noticing this is hard work.
So don't let anyone tell
you that this is easy.
And that's why it's called
mastering conflict cause
it's like earning your black
belt in conflict mastery
as you do these practices.
So for sure I wish it wasn't so hard.
Why does it have to be so hard?
Yeah.
Then of course the second question
is can I accept that it is hard,
right? That this isn't going
anywhere, anytime soon. Um,
and you know,
you might also ask yourself what's
unlikely to change about this situation?
Right? It's unlikely that she's going to
go back and have a different childhood.
Sally. It's unlikely that
the CFO is going to stop, uh,
putting pressure on the CEO to
have this conversation, right?
Those things are unlikely to change.
So can we live with them?
Can we learn how to master conflict and
live with what is rather than just keep
wishing that it somehow,
which is work itself out and go away.
Cause unless we master it, it's
not likely to. Third practice,
identify your values.
And we have three different kinds values
here to identify in most difficult,
in most in all difficult conflicts.
There's something running the show,
running the conflict that
I'm calling taboo values.
These are the things
that we all care about,
but we would never admit
that we care about them,
sometimes not even to our own selves.
We are so ashamed,
embarrassed about caring about these
things that we won't even let ourselves go
there. We'll push them down. We push them
away into some shadow side of ourselves,
right?
We don't want to look at that.
And that prevents the conflict
from having any movement,
any opportunity for movement
out of the stuck place.
Because until and unless we can take
those shadow taboo values and look at them
and talk about them with the other side,
with other people,
they're going to be running the show.
So ideal values are quite the opposite.
If you ask someone,
what do you really care about?
What drives your behavior in your life?
Those are their ideal values.
That's what they say is important to them.
So if we think about the
CEO, Bob, in this situation,
what would buy? You don't know him. Well,
I know him well. Um, but what do you,
what do you think Bob would say are
his ideal values? Thinking about the,
the company has created, it's
this high tech start up, um,
what would he say are important
to him? Just take a guess. I mean,
you don't know him. Company interests
before your own interests. Great. Yep.
Absolutely. Like collaborative.
Great. Yes, absolutely.
He cares about people.
He cares about employees in his company.
He's a caring person. So a value of his
might be care. Yup. Great. So what, what,
what's the value behind that? You
said people that, that they want the,
the products and services to
do well in the company. What,
what would you call that?
Maybe achievement.
Yeah.
Great.
Affinity for products,
great ambition for myself
and for the company. Yeah. So
you, you all hit it on the head, right?
These are the things that I knew about
him from having worked with him is that
he said, look, I'm a generous
person. I take care of my employees.
I'm an authentic person.
People know that.
What I say is how you know how I behave
in they're one in the same and I'm a
collaborative person, right? I
like people to work together.
That's what he said about himself.
That's what he believed to be true.
What about his current values?
How does he actually live his life?
So sometimes for some people,
if we're lucky,
our ideal values and our current values
are one and the same because we're
living in a way where our behavior
is aligned with our matches.
What we say is actually important to
us. For others, probably more of us.
Um, our ideal values might overlap a
little bit with our current values,
but we've got other things that are
really driving our behavior and for,
for some of us are ideal
values or one set of things.
And the way we live our life is a whole
other set of things. Right. So what, what,
what do you think might be his current
values? What's driving his behavior? Yeah.
Yeah.
So scarcity and compensation
might be running the show here.
So, well, let's see. So
I've got here authenticity.
He is authentic, right?
He says what he means.
And also that he's an adventurous person
too. So he's a risk taker, right in life.
Somebody you know taught him that risk
taking and having adventures is a good
thing. And he started a from eight
years ago and he's an adventurous guy.
What about his taboo values?
And I think this is really more like
what you were just saying, right? So
this is a person who really
wants power in his life,
wants authority in his life,
wants the financial stability that you
were just talking about yet pushes those
things down. Because at some point along
the way in his life, somebody told him,
it's okay to be generous.
It's okay to be collaborative.
It's okay to be authentic.
But boy,
if you ever dare tell somebody that
you want power or you want authority,
you want financial stability.
No, you've got to be adventurous.
You've got to be a risk taker.
That's his profile of his value.
That's what he learned
along the way in his life.
And so for him to come out and say,
I care about power,
authority and financial stability
for myself, you can't go there.
And as we said before,
if he can't go there for himself,
if he can't admit those things to himself,
they're completely undiscussable
with Sally as well.
So he needs to admit that these things
are important to him so that he can
discuss them with Sally and then
they have some place to move,
right? It might be that
he and Sally go, Hey,
actually we both care about financial
stability and that's something we actually
have in common.
Then you start to move more towards a
more classic collaborative or win win
negotiation, uh,
Opportunity. Next practice.
We're going to talk about emotions.
Negative emotions are core
to every difficult conflict.
It's basically,
it's impossible to have a difficult
conflict without having negative emotions
that come along with it.
I'm suggesting here that there are four
ways that we as humans typically respond
emotionally in difficult conflicts.
The more American culturally,
um,
assumed way is exploded. Others, right?
We get angry and we aggress either
physically or verbally or both.
We aggress it.
Others.
That's how we typically think
about it in this country at least.
But there's these three other ways as
well, right? We, we shut down with others,
right? Push, push, push, boom.
I'm not talking about my feelings,
I'm avoiding the situation and
we'll just see what happens.
But I'm going to avoid this at all costs.
Something else that we don't typically
talk about is that many of us actually
attack ourselves.
So while some of us attack the other,
some of us go inside and
feel so much shame and guilt.
We ruminate on that.
And somehow we think that that ruminating
is going to make those feelings get
better or go away. We're going to
figure them out finally. Right?
But what the research
tells us about ruminating,
especially about negative emotions,
is that it doesn't make those
negative emotions go away.
You don't ever figure them out. It
just makes them worse, not better.
And finally,
for some of us were,
so we've been taught
culture impacts. This, uh,
were so shut down.
We're even shut down to ourselves.
So we might be confused
and might be feeling hurt,
but we don't have the names for that.
And so we ourselves are
just emotionally shut down.
So what do we do about this?
If these are our typical
ways of responding?
Clearly none of them particularly helpful
in difficult conflicts. What do we do?
We transform them.
Can anyone tell me,
what do you see up on the
screen? What's this? A picture of
transformer. And can you tell
it's not such a great picture.
Can you tell what is the
transformer doing? Meditating. Yes,
we have a transformer meditating.
I understand that at Google. Uh,
many of us around here,
you know, meditate.
So I thought this would be an appropriate
picture to show you. Um, so you know,
transformers, how many of you
played with transformers as a kid?
Maybe you might still,
I know it's fun, right?
So transformers were these dolls or action
figures really that you would press a
button or do something you throw.
My son has one and you throw it on the
floor and it like turns into something
else.
It transforms into something else.
So why am I showing you a picture
of transforming meditator?
It's because the Buddhist brought a
2000 year old technology to help us
transform our emotions.
Now there are a ton of people out there
in the conflict space who will tell you
rather than transform your emotions,
what you want to do is you want to
try to make it so that people don't
experience negative emotions around you.
So give them what you know,
do things to help make it better.
And then people won't be angry at you.
But what I really want to
suggest is that that's,
that's like asking you
to tame a wild beast.
Complex conflicts are naturally
going to bring up negative emotions.
So I'm not going to ask you to tamp them
down or make them go away or try to do
something so that other people you
can, you know, you can do that.
You can try to make it so that other
people don't get angry or don't aggress
against you. But still these
negative emotions are going to arise.
So what do you do?
You sit and you let the emotions settle.
And in doing that,
usually what happens is those emotions
have the opportunity to transform into
something more constructive,
to not hum the Vietnamese Buddhist monk,
he talks about,
uh, a glass of water. So if
you're in the desert and you are,
you need to drink and you have this
one last glass of water and it's muddy,
it's full of mud. What do you do? You take
the glass of water or you set it aside,
you let the mud settle to the bottom,
and then on the top you have
the clear water to drink.
And that's another metaphor.
Another
idea.
Now,
what happens if you're not able
to transform these emotions?
You try to let them settle and they don't.
They're still,
these negative emotions are still present.
Okay?
One thing to do is to ask yourself,
what are my emotions trying to tell me?
Very often our emotions are
trying to send us messages.
It might be danger or
it might be opportunity.
And if we're shut off to our emotions and
we're not aware even of what they are,
it's not possible for us to hear the
wisdom in them. So I encourage you,
sit,
let them settle and then listen to what
they might be trying to tell you to do
or not do or say or not say.
That's my quick quick
advice about emotions.
Next practice.
Envision possible optimal outcomes.
What do I mean by this?
So often in difficult conflicts we are
looking at what happened in the past,
right? Who said it? We're blaming, it's
not my fault, it's all their fault.
We're so focused on whose
fault it is and blaming,
looking at what has gone wrong.
We're not at all aware of think that
how important it is to think about the
future and what we do want.
So this practice is aimed at helping
us look forward to the future.
And there are a few recommendations
that I have for best practice.
Ways to do this.
One is to use all five of your senses.
So we typically rely on seeing and hearing
what about smelling, tasting, touch,
and also our emotions actually.
So there's research that suggests that
if you use all these five senses plus
your feelings to visualize
what you want in the future,
or visualize your performance,
digitalize your app outcomes,
there's actually sports research on this.
People who visualize it were as likely
to achieve the outcomes they were seeking
as people who actually did
the practice of that sport.
So visualization works.
Okay.
Many of us come from fractured families.
Thanksgiving is around the corner,
right?
So what I encourage you to do is think
about a Thanksgiving meal that you might
be about to have and envision.
What could this be like without all that
conflict that normally comes along with
that dinner?
What could it be like to be
joyful and have love in the room?
What would it look like? What would it
sound like? What would it taste like?
Can you taste the Turkey?
Can you smell the food
wafting through the kitchen?
Can you imagine what it would be like
to hug and be with your friends or your
family?
If you can imagine it,
you bet you have a much better
chance of making that happen.
Can you feel those feelings much better
chance of making that happen then if you
don't envision it at all.
Next practice prevent unintended
negative consequences.
So again,
because we're often so focused on what
went wrong in the past and we are so
inaction mode, just trying to fix it,
right? People have talked about, well,
should I do this or should I do that?
And so we're just like all over the
place often trying to make things work.
And what happens is we're not thinking
ahead about the possible consequences of
our own actions.
We're not thinking about how we might
be contributing to the situation.
So has anyone heard of Suzy Welch?
And you want to know who? Susie,
who's Suzy Welch? Anyone know? All right.
So she is the spouse of Jack Welch who
was the former CEO of General Electric.
She is the former uh,
Harvard business review editor in chief.
She interviewed him for an article
she was writing. That's how they met.
And she also happens to have written a
book a few years ago called 10, 10, 10,
10 minutes, 10 months,
10 years, a life idea.
And the idea in her book
is very quite simple.
It's when you have an important
decision to make in life,
it can be really helpful to think about
the impact of that decision on yourself.
Not just today,
10 minutes from now,
but also 10 months from now and 10
years from now. Really fantastic idea.
The idea here in this practice is building
on that and it's not just a stretch
the time horizon,
but also stretch out who are you thinking
about your impact of your behavior on.
So typically we think about on yourself
now we think about what am I about to
do? How is my behavior that I'm
about to take going to impact me now?
So I'm saying think about it,
how is it going to impact you midterm
and how's it gonna impact you long term,
but also ask yourself how's it going to
impact the other side now midterm and
longterm,
and don't stop there because there's
some other very important people as we
discovered doing the map exercise who
are impacted by your behavior as well,
which is everyone else involved
in that conflict, right?
Others now mid term and long term.
So if we back up,
let's go back in time and think about Bob.
If he thinks about the impact of his
raising the idea on the street corner on
him now he's like, wow, that's so
great. I got it off my chest right.
Him mid term. All right, cool.
So now we've talked about it and probably,
you know,
we're going to change her compensation
package and longterm the company's
financial wellbeing will be,
we'll be good.
But what about on Sally now,
what do you think if he
took the time to think,
I'm going to bring this up on a
street corner. You said it before.
What's the impact on Sally of doing that?
Okay.
Right. She's fearful, she's
angry. She gets caught off guard.
And what's the impact on Sally
over the medium term or, Yup,
absolutely.
Right now she's completely shut down.
Conversation finished longterm.
Yeah,
absolutely. Trust is damaged, their
relationship is damaged for sure.
That is exactly what happened.
What about others?
So thinking about the whole company,
the executive team, the CFO,
uh, each of their families,
what about others?
What's the impact on,
on the company of his behavior?
He brings it up on the street corner now.
So for the company,
so it's negative all around. And for
the CFO, for the rest of the company,
also negative,
right?
Because now the CFO has been pressuring
the CEO to have this conversation and
now the whole thing got shut down,
right?
Midterm also shut down.
Company's losing money.
Sally's making,
making a ton of money and companies was
losing money and longterm, same thing.
So it can be really helpful. You want
to think about yourself as, you know,
like a chest master when you're playing.
How many people play chess out there?
Yeah. So when you play chess, right?
One of the things that you have to do
is you've gotta be thinking a few steps
ahead. And that's the same idea
here is be training yourself.
And this is a practice. It's
not easy for sure. Not Easy.
It is a practice to train yourself.
Uh, just like a chess master does.
To think a few steps ahead about what's
going to be the implications of my
actions today on all these other folks.
Over the long term.
That's the idea
and the reason to do this obviously,
right?
The purpose is it'll prevent you from
doing things that are going to cause
problems for you. That might even, it's
going to prevent disasters basically,
and it's going to set you up for success.
It's going to help you maximize the
outcomes that you're looking to achieve.
Final practice,
take courageous pattern breaking action.
What do I mean by pattern breaking action
and I'll, I'll ask that as a
real question. What do you think?
I mean pattern breaking. What does
that mean? You got it. You got it.
Something you typically won't do
as part of your normal routine.
You're breaking the pattern in your
behavior and how do you know that you're
breaking a pattern in your behavior
of how you typically do things?
It feels really uncomfortable.
It basically sucks,
right?
You feel like what is going on here?
This is so weird,
so strange.
I don't understand what's happening.
That's how you know you're doing
courageous pattern breaking action,
so it's going to feel weird.
Okay.
Unlike a few at many of the previous
practices that we just went through,
particularly the first one, second
one, right? Except what is observe,
what is this? Uh, the sixth one,
which was just think ahead about your
actions and what be like a chess master
and think ahead.
This final practice is all about action.
So it's great. You have to think
ahead and if you're only analyzing,
if you're only thinking ahead, right.
That's what when we started out you said,
well, I'm in my own head and I'm thinking
should I do this or should I do that?
If you end guaranteed failure
because you haven't done anything,
most,
well not guaranteed,
but most likely sometime every
once in a while avoiding, you know,
helps but not in difficult situation,
not in difficult conflicts.
Avoiding doesn't usually help.
It usually only makes things worse.
So a couple of pieces of advice about
how to take courageous pattern breaking
action. First one is, um,
mini experiments.
What do I mean by that?
So a different CEO who I was
consulting to a couple of years ago,
he got feedback. I wish it was
my job to give him the feedback.
I collected feedback
from his direct reports,
people who reported to him and I
delivered this report to him and the main
message of the report was,
you don't listen to your people.
They don't feel heard.
And he said,
uncharacteristically for him. He
said, you know what? You're right.
I don't.
And then he said,
I never have listened to anyone.
That's how I got where I am today.
Yeah,
on the playground.
As a kid,
I used to tell everyone else what to
do and they listened to me and that's,
that's how I've always been. So in that
moment, I said to him, first of all,
Kudos to you for
acknowledging your behavior.
And then it got you to
where you are today.
These people are ready to
quit on you. So you, you're,
you're thinking about how
can I do this differently?
My advice to him was do many experiments.
Don't expect that all of a sudden
you're going to just start listening to
everybody. Go home, be with
your partner or your spouse,
with your kids and listen to them
once a day. Only once, once a day.
Make it your practice to listen to them.
You might tell them what you think.
You've just heard them say,
you might check that you heard them right.
Do whatever you need to do to make sure
that you listen to those people and then
come back and tell me, I'm your
coach. Tell me how it went.
That's an example of start
small once a day and start safe.
Do it at home, test it out, see
how it goes. Mini experiments.
Second idea
comes to us from Nike.
Just do it right.
Don't hesitate.
You gotta just at some point, right?
At some point you got to just do it.
Has anyone ever done an aids ride
or a three day breast cancer walk?
Anybody here? No. I should do
it. It's really great experience.
Maybe kind of almost almost did it.
So a man named Dan Pallotta was the
original founder of the aids rides and the
breast cancer.
The three day breast cancer walks with
Avon and I did one of the breast cancer
walks, uh, many years ago and
he, Dan Pallotta was there.
He gave a speech at
the closing ceremonies,
and in that speech he said that he had a
friend named Alan and Alan was the kind
of person who didn't hesitate when
the right thing needed to be done.
He just did it.
So Alan used to drive around in his car
with blankets and food in the back seat.
And when he saw somebody on
the street who needed help,
he gave them what they needed.
That's what I'm asking of you today is
that at a certain point you got to just
do it.
So I want to leave you with an
invitation and with a promise.
The invitation is to actually
put these practices into play.
Practice them in your real life.
It's not going to be easy.
I can guarantee you that it's gonna make
you go deep. You're going to go deep.
You're gonna.
I'm asking you to look at things that
you have not wanted to look at about
yourself in your life about others.
And yet
the promise that I can make you
is that as you do those things,
as you practice those practices,
you will come to experience what
it's like to be a conflict master.
You'll walk into your office and
you'll be thrilled to be there,
to be with the people at work and at
home who bring you love and enjoy.
And what's even better
is that it's contagious.
So as you master conflict,
you lead the way for others as well.
You allow them to master
conflict in their own lives too.
And in that way you build masterful teams,
masterful organizations,
communities, masterful families.
Okay.
It's all right there
for you.
So stay in conversation
with each other with me.
Please let me know how your mini
experiments go. I want to hear about it.
Stay in conversation,
stay in practice.
I've a more specific invitation for you.
I'm actually teaching in a couple
of weekends but it's sold out.
But the next one is March 4th through
sixth 2017 the weekend workshop where we
go much deeper into each of these seven
practices is at Columbia University.
So that's my invitation to you as well.
Feel free to come and let me know or
email me for those of you watching online.
Happy to get you connected and registered.
Thank you so much. It's been a total
pleasure being with your mom today.
I had a question around timeframes,
so that's a lot of steps and
then I liked the process,
but what would you say is,
is like a,
so in that situation with Bob was like
what time frame does that really all take?
Cause it sounds like a lot.
Yeah,
so he's on a street corner and he's the
middle of yelling back and you're saying
what does he do then? Right? Yeah.
So typically as, as I said, emotions,
negative emotions are involved in
almost every difficult conflict.
So often it's actually a matter of us
being aware of what's happening in our
body.
How many of you would say you're on a
regular basis aware of what's happening in
your body? All right, cool, great.
Are you guys from the meditation,
the Mindfulness Group? That's
awesome. Right? Usually.
So maybe about 10% of the room.
It's a, it's, it's difficult work.
Um,
so
in order to get in touch with what's going
on, you have to first be in practice,
being aware of sitting, feeling,
what am I feeling? What's going on,
what am I feeling?
Typically emotions are linked to
bodily sensations that we have.
So if I know that when I get angry,
my face starts to turn hot and red and
my heart starts to beat faster and my
pulse, you know, and my hands
get all tingly or something.
That is my cue to take
a couple deep breaths,
calm it down,
try that.
Either not yell back in the first place
or stop yelling in the midst of it.
Um, and it's, I would say when
you're stuck in the moment,
the emotions is the place to go,
to really calm yourself down.
And you can say to someone, look, I'm
not proud of what is happening here.
And I'd like us to take a break.
Can we take a break?
Cool it off and come
back in an hour tomorrow,
you know,
next week,
let's think this through and really come
back and have a better conversation.
So that's just, you know, a
quick answer to your question,
but for sure these practices are,
and the reason why we call them
practices is because they're meant to be
practiced over time to help prevent you
from getting in difficult conflicts in
the first place. Um, but you know,
or use them after you just
had a big blowout with
someone or something or you're
ruminating about something,
use them as a way to ask yourself,
how could I get back on track here?
How can I get back on track?
But you do need the time to sit quietly.
So taking a break is,
is a good idea when you're in the midst.
So the question is how do you
identify your taboo values?
And once you've identified them,
what do you do with that? Well,
first of all, for some of you, we,
we made some printed copies of a
sheet that walks you through the seven
practices. And on that sheet
there's a list of values.
So it's a little cheat sheet.
And I recommend using either this list
that I provided for you or some lists of
values.
I'm sure if you go online you can find
a list of what our typical values and
look through them. And um,
the advice is make your,
of what are the taboo values in my
life, generally speaking, right?
We all have them. So you want to ask
yourself what are things like for example,
power and authority were
true for this CEO. Um,
for some people it has to do with
affluence. Money is a big one. Um,
independence,
uh,
the, we all have different,
different taboo values and in fact,
I've done this exercise with many,
many groups where we notice that some
people's taboo values show up on other
people's ideal values and vice
versa depending on how you grew up,
what messages you got sent. So
it's, it's deep introspective work.
You might work with a friend
or a colleague or a coach
to help you identify what
might be some of these
taboo values for me. Uh,
and then the second part
of your question was,
and what do I do with them once I
know what they are? Really two things.
The first is admit to yourself
that this is true for you.
And you that,
that you may not be proud of it.
And then the second piece is,
can you find a way to make
this discussable with the
other person? So, you know,
you might say to them,
look,
I just realized for the first time in
my life that it's very hard for me to
admit I,
I actually do need autonomy in my life,
or I do need to be,
to feel powerful or to feel respected.
Those are important to me.
I've always thought that those are not
things I should want. But now I get that.
I want them.
And I'm telling you this because I want
to fess up to my part in this conflict.
My part is that I wasn't clear
with myself and so I couldn't,
there was no way I could have been clear
with you that those were things that
were important to me and they've been
driving my behavior in this conflict and
I'm not proud of it.
Um,
and then
see what, see how they respond
to that. My, my hunch, what
I've seen to be true for,
for so many of my clients is that people
respond really well to that kind of
conversation cause they see how authentic
and how honest you're being with them
and that you're taking responsibility,
right? Like we're going from the place of,
it's all your fault.
I have nothing to do with it too.
Wow. You know, I really,
I really get how much I've
contributed here. Is that helpful?
One last question. Yeah. Um,
if you go back to the previous slide
to ask you about the, you know, the,
the research that had gone through to,
you know,
create these seven steps because, um, I'm,
I'm wondering like is this
the most parsimonious a set?
Because if I were thinking to myself
what the procedures I would take, yeah,
I would want to, you know,
understand myself, understand others,
I would want to maybe calm my own
emotions and then bro, you know,
breach the topic in a tactical manner.
The other person in, in different,
different ways. Are these other steps,
like envisioning the optimal outcome or
mapping out some taboo values?
Is that even necessary as steps?
Hmm, that's a great
question. So first of all,
let me say thank you for your challenge.
I love parsimony.
I think it's a great
challenge. Um, second of all,
I hope I didn't, it's possible
that I did say the word steps,
but I'm calling these practices
because they're not a,
I presented them in a sequential order,
but they're not meant to be that you
must go through each one of these seven
steps.
They're not steps at all actually there
practices that you can cultivate in
order to become a master
of difficult conflicts.
And so for some conflicts it may be
that what you just said, you know,
there are three pieces here that are
really helpful for you and go for it.
If that's true for you,
um,
for other conflicts or for other people,
other practices might be
more helpful to them. Uh,
and I, you know, I take your challenge,
I'm in the midst of writing the book,
so it's not done yet. Um, but I'll,
I'll say one more thing that it might,
might be helpful for you in,
in answering the question,
which is these seven practices are,
what I have seen is missing from
the existing conflict literature,
scholarly literature and
practical literature,
literature and practice. So, um,
some of the bestselling books of the
last four decades did an amazing job of
helping people deal with
these routine conflicts.
And yet they never talked about,
you know,
envision what it could be like.
They talk about create options
that will work for both parties,
but I think this takes that
idea in a different direction.
This takes that idea,
like another step further and say,
really get yourself to
imagine what it could be like.
So it may be that you already
do that and you don't,
I'm that practices and speak to you,
but
[inaudible].